good morning everyone we're a little bit
behind this schedule
so i'd like to get started
so everyone please take your seats
april 19th session of the science
technology and energy committee to begin
i would like you all to rise
and join representative partial in our
all right thank you we are here today to
pass judgment on the remaining bills
before us
year
only
yes that's true
so
so before we begin i'd like to introduce
a couple of substitutes that we have
here this morning representative
laflamme who was with us last tuesday
is back again to substitute for
representative pementel
and representative kelly
is here
as well and he is substituting for
representative
representative vincent
so welcome to you both glad to have you
we hope to pursue proceed fairly quickly
through our list of bills here today
if
however the
discussions drag on to the point where
we can't get through everything
before 11 30 we will break at 11 30 for
lunch
and then we will come back and finish
the bills
so with that i think we can begin
so i'm going to now open an executive
this is a bill to
relative to the purchase of output of
or relative to the burgess biopower
facility
and
the majority has decided that we are
going to recess
this executive session until 10 a.m on
10 a.m on april 26th
so with that bill being in recess
or that executive session being in
recess
we can now move on to the rest of our
agenda
we're not necessarily going to be
exacting these bills in the order that
they're listed
in the scheduling notice we may take
them out of order but we will get
through them all eventually
so the first bill we're going to do is
i'm going to open an exec session on
senate bill 263
and i recognize representative platt for
a motion
mr chair i moved to itl senate bill 263.
the chair recognizes representative
white
i second
it has been moved and seconded that we
judge
senate bill 263 to be itl
is there any discussion
representative platt i would just uh
support my motion by saying that this
sort of thing can happen without
government involvement at all
a good point additional comments
representative sabzich
thank you mr chairman
um well well i do agree with the
representative platt that this thing
could happen without government
involvement
i think having
having our state government
make a statement about wanting to have
young people involved in some of these
issues is also a very powerful statement
and if we just say you know
you guys can just do this on your own uh
bear in mind many of these people many
of these young people are minors it's
not like they can organize and demand
things on their own they need some
support and they are the future of this
this our state
uh i think it's it there's no real big
harm in passing this bill
because we would just let them have a
say at the table we still have the final
say on everything so i don't understand
the itl here but that's just my opinion
thank you further discussion on
i will vote no one the itl simply
because
we have experimented in my town with
youth on the school board and found that
their opinions and their insights
are invaluable
and
i look at some of the youth that have
gone through there and now see them on
the city council
so this to me this youth environmental
core
council it's a training ground because
let's face it
some of us are going to
and i'm going to speak for myself have
to drop out
we just can't do it anymore and some of
these people that are on
these types of councils and youth
forums
are going to take our place
and i always think that organization
with some rules and some
ways of operation is much better than
just an ad hoc
committee
thank you representative thomas is
recognized well thank you mr chair um
uh i looked at this bill um
carefully and was intrigued by it
but one of the key
points that was made uh during the um
hearings i won't say key points but one
of the key references that was made was
it was to the education chair uh
representative ladd who said that he was
in full support of this bill
uh and it would be good for education
and that intrigued me so i asked uh
representative ladd uh the other day
what he thought of this bill and he said
what bill
and i said and i explained to him what
the bill was i said you're a co-sponsor
on it he says that may be but you know
uh from what you described to the bill
it doesn't sound like something that
would be all that beneficial and i
perhaps someone called me a long time
ago and asked me about it and my name
got put on here i really didn't didn't
even realize my name was on there he
says he doesn't and like was mentioned
earlier uh he didn't believe that this
type of council needed to have you know
government support
so after hearing uh representative
vlad's comments on that i decided that i
would agree with with the motion to ietl
something that's best left out
okay further comment on this
legislation representative mcgee
thank you mr chairman
uh
as i recall the youth who came to
testify for us they were quite
impressive
and they answered every question and
they
gave the reasoning behind the bill
in terms of having their voices included
in the conversations that we're having
so i disagree that it's not something
government should be doing i think it's
one of the easy lifts that we have
to enable this type of a council so that
the youth can be
[Music]
present and involved and as
representative kelly pitts alluded to i
think i mentioned it in the hearing
that a pipeline be set up so that those
youth can learn how to interoperate with
the government how to get things done
i think there's nothing but upside to a
bill like this so i don't understand why
thank you
we already have a youth advisory council
in fact one of the young people who
testified was a member of the youth
advisory council
but seems redundant to create yet
another youth advisory council
and when i spoke to representative ladd
about this
this bill he mentioned that very fact he
said we already have a youth advisory
council we don't need another one
so is there any further
discussion of this bill
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the role on the motion of itl for senate
representative thomas
yes representative harrington yes
representative notter yes representative
mirner yes representative platfors
representative berezni yes
representative bernardi yes
representative campbell's
not present
okay
representative pleasure yes
representative white yes representative
samsic no representative callie pitts
representative mann no representative
oxendum
not present
okay
uh representative lewicki yes
representative kelly uh representative
kelly yes
no
representative mcgee
no representative williams
no
representation no
representative
and representative partial
help and the chair
yes
eleven
eight nine nine
no nay
and two not present
so by a vote of 11 to 9
the committee judges senate bill 263 to
be
an expedient to legislate
so i will
close the exact session on senate bill
and i would ask if there would be a
minority report and
representative callie pitts will write
the minority report
you have that for your green sheet
okay
i will now open an exec session on
senate bill 395.
395 is relative to the broadband
and
i will recognize representative lewicki
for a motion
um thank you mr chairman i move out to
okay could you make a uh
a motion on the amendment itself um i
moved that we passed the amendment
okay it's been moved by representative
loicke that we passed the amendment to
senate bill 395
chair recognized representative murder
amendment
2022-1624
the wiki uh moved to that amendment so
you can second it is that correct i
much okay so i will speak to the
amendment
now during the public hearing on this
bill
which was submitted by
there was a
bill
that
tried to
talk about how we might
increase the deployment of wireless
communications throughout the state
and
there was a lot of ambiguity and a lot
of vagueness in the bill
and it was suggested
by
some
some of the wireless vendors
that
we mimic
what we're doing for broadband and
create
a wireless deployment initiative and
grant fund we already have a
broadband deployment initiative and
grant fund
so this bill creates a similar
initiative and fund
for wireless
development
and in fact the language of the bill
copies or or is a duplicate of the
broadband deployment initiative and
grant fund bill it's the same
basic language
although it affects a different part of
statute and
was changed
to focus on wireless as opposed to
broadband
senator khan was fine with this
amendment and there was no opposition to
it
when we discussed it it was
the the basic idea of the amendment was
discussed at the end of the public
hearing
and
so i have prepared this amendment
to carry through on this effort
and that
is the basics of the amendment so is
there any discussion on this amendment
representative harrington is recognized
thank you mr chairman just a couple of
questions um
first on the bottom of
page two
it talks about federal funds received by
the state for the purpose of expanding
or improving internet access or wireless
conductivity should be credited to the
wireless deployment grant fund does that
how does that match up with the
broadband one because you've got
improving internet access generally
talks about broadband so
is the money going to go to the wireless
deployment fund or the broadband
deployment fund
for improving the internet
that's a good question and it was raised
to me
just this morning
that the word shall on line 37 should
probably be may
but there was no time to generate a new
amendment
this session here this morning so
my recommendation is that we pass this
amendment as is
and
the senate will probably when they see
that
word shall instead of may they will
probably ask for they will non-concur
and ask for a committee of conference
and we'll fix that word in the committee
of conference okay and a follow-up
follow-up okay uh in the
just above that in the paragraph it says
in addition to state appropriations
this
bill does not uh amendment does not
appropriate any money it just makes a
depository available if and when money
was appropriated whether it from the
state of the federal government
yes that is correct thank you
any further discussion on this bill
i hate to be a
big mouth but i don't think we should
wait for the senate to possibly go to a
community committee conference
there's no guarantee that they will they
may see this and just let it go through
if we believe
that this should be changed we should
change it and if it's such a minor
change it can be changed and brought
back next week if ols can't get it done
today
okay
that's a good point representative
lewicki uh thank you mr chairman it
still isn't clear to me whether we're
doing an either or where it's either
internet or
cell phone service or whether it is two
okay thank you for that comment
representative creation
thank you um in the original bill uh it
mentions that a municipality is eligible
to apply for a grant is that still
accurate in this one i only see grants
so the bill sets up rulemaking
or
requires rulemaking
by the department of business and
economic affairs relative to grant
application
and distribution procedures
concepts
for
rule
making
by the
so
i'm not sure if that answers your
question but uh if you could look at the
the paragraphs
on page 2 lines 5 through
or 16 to see if that answers your
question
okay follow up
follow up
i guess i'm just wondering whether um a
municipality could be the originator of
such a you know a petition for
um a project or if it has to come from
the provider
well there's nothing in this legislation
that would
prohibit a municipality from applying
for
such a project the way i read it
it doesn't specifically
say that a music municipality can
initiate a project but it doesn't say it
can't
representative mcgee
thank you mr chairman
um starting on line 27 that section
roman numeral 4 says the department of
business and economic affairs shall not
as a condition of an award of grant
money
impose any requirement state regulation
or other term or condition of service
that differs from the applicants
terms or conditions of service in its
other service areas so it's kind of
implied that the applicant
will be
the utility or
or the service provider i guess the
service provider exactly yeah but not
the municipality
to representative cretian's point it
sounds like it's written
so that the applications being made are
not being made directly by
municipalities who might be interested
in the grant money so
okay thank you for that comment
i guess uh thank you for taking the
question i don't understand that because
we a couple of years ago
made it so that municipalities
could initiate projects
by reason of bonding
and why municipalities
then could not
apply for a grant
rather than a bond
i don't know and i think that should be
clarified we
it seemed to me
obviously clear that in all
the man machinations about broadband and
cell
service that we did clearly want
municipalities to be able to make
arrangements
to obtain funds to initiate those
projects
and
it would it's a different bill but it
does one
does one overshadow the other or does
one go into conflict with the other that
i'd like to know
okay we have a couple of folks who
helped prepare this uh an amendment here
tonight so i'm going to ask them to
comment on this question
of whether or not this bill excludes
a municipality from applying for a grant
and if so why
please let us know who you are
good morning members of the committee my
name is maura weston i'm here this
morning representing 18t
and i have with me owen smith who is the
president of att for northern new
england
i'll take a stab at answering the
question and then i'll let owen fill in
in the arena of wireless we're we're
talking about quite a different business
model
than we were with broadband
and yes there is the opportunity for
municipalities to bond
to deploy infrastructure in partnership
with private providers
that's a very different
initiative
than this initiative
this is really the creation of a fund
for wireless providers
to
apply for grants
to deploy in areas where there is no
mobile wireless coverage
and the reason why and here i'll let
owen fill in the reason why
municipalities can't apply
for these particular grants
is that they don't have spectrum
so
in a wireline world
they can
partner with somebody they can acquire
uh fiber
and they can deploy
but that's a very different business
model than the wireless world and i'll
let owen because he's smarter take it
good morning owen smith with at t um and
i think mark covered it pretty well
we
have spent billions of dollars on
spectrum so we are using our spectrum
that we have here in new hampshire to
deploy um as maura stated a municipality
would not have that and they would not
have the ability to to utilize that
with regular wire line broadband they
can partner with a consolidated or a
comcast
that's not how it would work
and of course we would work
with the municipality of which we wanted
to provide service or improved service
on their permitting process so that
that's how that would work
okay so just to clarify to make and make
sure i understand this
you're saying that municipalities can't
apply because municipalities
don't have any
spectrum to use to develop wireless
service okay thank you representative
harrington
thank you mr chairman another thing to
think about is i think was just alluded
to is that broadband is over a wire
which is a fixed from point a to p point
b if you put up a cell tower in town a
it's also going to be broadcasting into
maybe town b town d town c who knows
where and it's just it's not practical
to try to say one town is going to have
jurisdiction over other towns cell
service and let's be honest we really
don't want municipalities getting in the
business of being telephone companies
because they don't know how to do it and
most places where attempts like that
have been tried to get screwed up
completely let's leave the experts do
what they're good at and the towns can
help with uh coordinating through their
permitting process but you really can't
have a wireless setup by a town because
wireless doesn't know town boundaries it
doesn't stop at the town line
thank you representative samsic
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
coming and taking our question here um
let me ask you this why does a
for-profit business like yours need a
grant to do these things
so um i was here a week ago and uh got
into that a little bit and i'll speak
for for att which is a for profit
private company
who has spent over the last three years
120 million dollars on our network here
in new hampshire a lot to do with
firstnet which is the public safety
network that we built when all is said
and done it works for our commercial
customers as well
and
even with that level of investment there
are places
that still
don't have
adequate cell coverage and
prior to firstnet
there's there was no business case to go
into an area
in many areas in this many areas that
we're talking about in new hampshire and
elsewhere that still need the coverage
there's no
there's no return on investment
we get
x amount of money for our budget every
year and it's prioritized and you know a
town uh like
um
what was the town we used
nelson
um
a town like nelson just isn't a high
enough priority for at t to spend its
own capital when we need to improve
coverage um you know maybe along 93 or
in manchester because of capacity it's
not that we don't want to but we go
through this prioritization
so i i don't know if that answers your
question with with firstnet with
firstnet that went out the window it
didn't matter on an roi we committed to
building 34 sites here in new hampshire
and a lot of other ones and we did it
regardless
follow-up
well exactly to the point that you're
talking about i understand that some
areas are not as profitable because
they're so far away or remote or
difficult to get to but we previously
had a bill we were discussing about the
carrier of last resort for fixed uh
telephone lines and the argument was
there is enough wireless options for
these people to go to and that's why we
don't need that anymore but it seems to
me what you're saying is
that you're not obligated to serve those
people necessarily if it's not
financially viable
that's true we aren't obligated i will
say that we have
97 of the population covered with
wireless um but that doesn't help a
little town like lisbon or
some of the other towns that would like
to have coverage so
again i think this is the vehicle to to
help get that coverage in those areas
we're going to go and we're going to
improve the coverage in manchester in a
long 93
just because that's what competition
does and uh but some of these smaller
areas are gonna
um are not gonna get the attention
within the time frame that the time
thank you representative flett has a
question
yes
if i were here during the public hearing
i could have asked the question but i
wasn't so i'm doing it now with your
permission
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking the question
i view this as sort of akin to the rural
electric cooperative model when uh in
the 30s when electricity was extended
but instead of a government entity it's
it's
uh using the private entity instead it's
the same model is that correct
pretty much yes and would you have a uh
level of penetration which you can't
you can cover profitably so that that's
a benchmark when you go in asking for
grants that you blow that and here's
what you need
essentially to
to at least break even
we won't break even we have operating
costs that are associated with a site
that we build um
in one of these areas that will be for
the life of our our term there 20 years
30 years plus
and so there's a huge operating expense
what this does is help us with a capital
investment which again would love to go
to lisbon but
in in the scheme of things in priority
it's not going to happen for
who knows when
representative creation
you had your hand up no representative
mcgee
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um mike what's right here
um
when you talk about the various small
places that are underserved do you have
a plan around how you would be applying
for the money because i think
the concern that i hear from
representative samsuch and others is
that the places that are
least well served may be the very last
people to be served so
so the question would be is there any
plan uh for going after this money
in order to take those places in the
state and bring them up
where they need to be
and you know are there way more than
there's money available or does it seem
like this grant program is going to
actually help new hampshire
solve for all of its gaps so i think
this bill will help significantly
towards um you know and i think i said
this last week i i don't i'm not going
to sit here and say that any provider is
going to get 100 percent of the state of
new hampshire or any other state covered
it's just nearly impossible to do but um
you know we can get a lot closer to 100
percent
i think we're
you know high 80s
geographically covered
so i think this can can really help is
there a plan in place
has at t put a plan in place for this
funding
we have worked with other municipalities
and other states
indian tribes and have done a couple of
these programs where we have received
grants and have built a tower on an
indian reservation in nevada that's uh
but we're in the very early stages so
very much like everybody here we're not
sure how this will work uh you know the
the devil's in the details and and we
are anxious to see
um what what the the
bea puts together and will work to help
uh make that happen
i've been here long enough to see grants
that are applied for go awry
that we're going to
quote unquote to the last mile and we
don't uh
and
it sounds to me
that even with this particular federal
grant we won't
what i'm asking you is when this grant
comes out or
is as with every federal grant there are
stipulations
things that you must do
can the state add any stipulations
to that grant in other words i'll say
nelson and i'm going to plead ignorant i
don't even know where nelson is i'm
going to be honest
but if they have no service and it is
not um
business-wise a good investment to
invest in nelson is there any way that
the state
or the federal government can ensure
so
i think the way the process will work
and i think that the bea needs to work
all of this out and we would like to
work with them on that but um we we
would say you know we would like to go
to nelson and build a cell site and
you know cover the area
and
i think that would
that would
start us with going to the town of
nelson
and proposing to build a cell site going
through their permitting process
which would
have us show our existing coverage
the proposed coverage
let's say that they would approve it
based on our presentation and all the
environmental stuff and so forth that
goes through it which takes sometimes a
year or two then we would go back to the
bea and say
here we go so so we've got the permit to
build it so can i follow up
yes follow-up so now we do have a
process
to
[Music]
quasi ensure that towns
different towns and different areas
by going through the bea can
get served
thank you
i would like to add representative pitts
i direct you to
12065 roman 2 which says very clearly
eligible projects shall provide wireless
infrastructure in areas unserved by
or lacking consistent mobile wireless
coverage
and
that is uh in the establishment of the
initiative itself and then there is a
rulemaking section that follows and we
again look forward to working with bea
to ensure those areas uh are prioritized
thank you
further discussion representative
lewicki uh thank you mr chairman thank
you for taking my question i still have
a question as to whether this is a
single part of money that covers both uh
fiber and cell service or whether we are
talking about two separate entities
so it's two separate entities um it
would be a separate fund for uh mobile
wireless which includes um connectivity
through the internet but this this would
be a mobile wireless 4g lte 5g which
which is not only a voice service but
it's a data service that's where the
internet comes in
follow-up um
this question still is if nelson gets
a cell tower does that mean that uh
some other town roxbury does not get
fiber
additional representative partial
thank you chair
now
my understanding is that there are
several competitors in all of these
areas it's not just a t that is built
they're building towers
and so that would potentially mean that
even if a t were to come in and work
with nelson to develop cell tower
technology in nelson
if i'm a us cellular or a verizon
customer i'm still going to suffer from
lack of service unless i'm calling 9-1-1
is that true correct
um would you say that to some degree
perhaps a badly needed subsidy but a
subsidy that would uh
allow you to divert
uh the other funding to uh
rolling out
5g technology along the 93 courier
manchester places that uh where you
can more profitably put your resources
where this would
potentially under serve those
could potentially serve those other
underserved areas
before you that's hard question before
you answer that question i would like to
remind the members that we have an
amendment before us and your questions
should be about the amendment
not about the overall subject that the
bill addresses
maybe face my question then you may
refresh your question that's because i i
do think the amendment does some
distance in covering
my concern
but i still am concerned that uh
even with the amendment the one line
about
targeting underserved areas
still
with that amendment there and with that
money available that will mean that you
can
potentially
realize resources
to uh
other more profitable areas within your
company
so i think i think that's up to the the
bea to to help manage um
you know i think we're looking at the
areas that need
the the most help
um you know and i know this area hooks
it around 93 is an issue for some
providers it's not for us
so
you know i don't think this this
grant fund is going to solve all of new
hampshire's problems and there's no
guarantee that um any of these you know
nelson will get service but um you know
it's
it
i i believe this is to truly help in
okay thank you further discussion
representative bresny did you have a
question
remember it's a question about the
amendment only right
uh it wasn't was it a question it was
just a comment uh to uh what
representative mcgee asked about having
a process or i believe um
and on page two line 14 it says
establishment of a process that promotes
wireless connectivity statewide
so i assume that will be
something that the bea does
to figure out which towns
should have or should be encouraged to
get these grants
okay thank you i'd like to thank the two
of you for answering our questions i
think you cleared up a lot of ambiguity
thank you for the opportunity thank you
and if you could just turn off that
microphone there thank you appreciate
that
all right so
seeing
uh further dis uh representative
creation has a last minute question
sorry i do have another question um i
was just hoping you could clarify for me
so
um
roman three on page one says
eligible projects shall be evaluated as
part of a competitive process can you
just clarify who is going to be doing
that evaluation
is it the bea
okay thank you any further comments uh
representative kelly
yeah i don't want to step on any toes so
i'll keep it brief but my i was just
comparing this against the broadband uh
initiative package that we passed last
year um the my my there are two notable
things missing from this bill that were
included in the
last year's legislation and that were a
50 cap on on costs so total cost of the
project being 50 percent uh supplied by
the broadband provider in this case it
would be a wireless provider and then
the second one being a
uh
a stipulation that eligible cost shall
not include operating expenses or
recurrent costs i don't i just wanted to
point that out so you know i had those
in front of me okay thank you
representative leflam did you have a
comment
thank you mr chairman i guess my comment
would have been for the representative
from att but i'll put it out there
anyway
um
there are areas of the state up in my
neck of the woods
where major corridors
u.s route 2
u.s route 3
new hampshire route 16
heavily traveled roads which do not have
access to cell phone service
you're driving along and all of a sudden
that's it you don't have cell phone
service anymore and i was curious if
this program
um
would
enable
carriers such as a t
to it or or encourage them to increase
uh cell phone service even in places
that are unincorporated and do not have
i'll take a stab at answering that
question since you weren't here for the
public hearing
the whole purpose of this grant
initiative
is we know the federal government is
going to be providing
millions possibly even
tens or even hundreds of millions of
dollars for broadband expansion
and potentially wireless expansion
and this fund
is a place for some of those federal
funds to
to reside to be deposited in
and
the goal would be
to expand
wireless coverage
wherever it's needed so the answer to
your question is yes
that's part of what this is all about
uh representative partial
thank you chair uh has it been discussed
to your knowledge uh any i any uh
potential of sending this to an interim
study
that hadn't uh
come up in any of the discussions i've
had no i just feel i may i find urgency
for a bill to address some of these
areas
and i think this amendment goes a long
ways in answering some of my concerns
but i still don't know if it really
gives me all the solace i would like to
go forward to vote for this bill i
really i'm still kind of on the fence
i'll be very honest
okay thank you
representative platt
i on the other hand think this is
critically necessary to get federal
funds when they come instead of missing
them and with respect to 50 i don't know
if that's applicable to a wireless
i don't know that could cover the exp
the uh
cost recovery needs to be higher than
that in some cases so just i wouldn't
want a hamstring let let the let the
process take place
representative harrington
thank you mr chairman may i suggest this
we seem to have some
legitimate concerns here but we also
have the issue of who knows when the big
federal dump truck is going to load up
and say you want your money if we have
no place to put it they're just going to
go to maine
so maybe this committee could have an
unofficial committee that gets together
with this and then presents some changes
to the senate when it goes there because
it will have to go back to the senate
and that'll give us an opportunity to
address
what i think of some legitimate concerns
and also not delay for another year with
the possibility of losing federal funds
so that's a suggestion
all right that's a that's an idea
so
i have asked kristen to obtain a new
amendment that changes the word shall to
the word
may
on um
i forget
line what 27
37 on page two
however to follow representative
harrington's
suggestion of just a moment ago
we could pass this amendment
and then
ask the senate to non-concur
form a committee of conference
and address the issue
that representative harrington raised in
a committee of conference
so i would like to get a sense of the
committee of what you would prefer to do
we could either pass this amendment
with the idea that it would go to a
committee of conference or wait for the
new amendment
which changes the word shall to may
representative pled
my druthers is to get the new amendment
because it's cleaner and you still may
want to discuss with the sun and some
changes
okay
representative berezni
would any of the changes um that would
be discussed in the committee of
conference affect the the grant the
receiving of the grant part because if
if it doesn't then we can just pass this
and and have this implemented and then
next year
uh make any small fixes to the
implementation
it shouldn't
it shouldn't affect it at all
shall or may
simply means
it must or it can so
it's a fairly simple change
any further representative callie pitch
i would rather wait for the amendment
that's coming rather than pass this
amendment
and i thought what i heard you say
representative foss was that when this
goes back to the senate
there may be room for testimony there as
well
well what will happen
whether we pass this amendment or
a new amendment that changes the word
shall to may
is that it will go back to the senate
and the senate will have to vote to
concur
or to non-concur
or to non-concur and request a committee
of conference
so if we communicate with the senate
that we want a committee of conference
then we can get one
i'm sure they'll they'll go along with
that
but the first step would be to pass an
an
amendment and my sense is that the
committee does not want to pass this
amendment because it has
one word in it that's wrong
so what i'm going to do next is i'm
going to call the role i'm going to ask
the clerk to call the role and ask
everybody in the committee to vote no
to reject this amendment
and then
i will recess this executive session
until kristen informs us that she has a
new amendment that fixes that one word
then we will resume this executive
session
and pass that amendment
so if that seems acceptable to everyone
then i'll ask the clerk to call the roll
on
the adoption of the amendment whose
number i don't have 1624h
1624h and i urge everyone to vote no
representative thomas
no harrington mr harrington
representative notter
no representative mirner no
representative platfords no
representative berezni no representative
bernardi now
representative pleasure
no
representative white no representative
samsic no represents cali pitts no
representative man no representation not
here right representative lewicki no
representative kelly
no represent mcgee no representative
mcwilliams no representation no
representative leflamb no
representative uh partial no
in the chair
no okay that's 20 voting no no yeses and
uh two is too absent
okay by a vote of 20 to nothing then we
have rejected amendment number 16 24 h
and we will await
the the arrival of a new amendment
which
we don't know when that will happen so
so i will recess this executive session
on uh house bill 395
the senate bill 395
until such time as we get
that new
amendment
so that gives us a new opportunity to
open an executive session on senate bill
and
the chair recognizes representative
mcgee
yes mr chairman i
i passed out an amendment which is
2022-1631h
and that amendment is uh i would like to
put that amendment up for ought to pass
so do you have a motion a motion of
ought to pass on
amendment
2022 1631
thank you oh to adopt
do i have to say a doctor second
second representative mcgee has moved
that we adopt amendment
16318 representative thomas is
recognized
second okay representative thomas
seconds the motion
representative mcgee would you like to
discuss the amendment yes thank you
um we've had conversations outside of
our committee room amongst ourselves um
and with other interested stakeholders
about what we were attempting to
accomplish with 262
and where sort of the pain points were
within our own committee about
disagreements about what how far we
wanted to go and what we wanted to pass
within that
original bill
and so
what the amendment does
is it
it removes sections of the bill
one two three four five
and then renumbers items six through
nine
to be one through four
and then this amendment shows the
changes in the language what was
to what was formally section six so i
know that's kind of confusing but
um
and uh the chairman and i work together
to make sure that the language here was
acceptable to basically all the
stakeholders who had been involved
in terms of what we can get passed at
this point so
what is preserved is
the ability to be
added to
group
net metering with a custom generator so
that language is preserved and the
interconnection piece that
was up uh was a cause for significant
concern
because there isn't really a process for
consistent application of the
interconnection fees
uh was preserved
and i have to look at the bill to
tell you what else is in there i don't
know mr chairman if you have anything
you want to add
while you're looking that up i will just
point out
that the amended language
in the new section one
about
group host requirements is a language
that
we came up with with the help of the
department of energy right and
basically what it fixes is a problem
such as the one exists in londonderry
where their fire station has solar
panels on the roof
or
somewhere nearby and
they
net meter
that
because of the way these the existing
statute is worded they cannot become
part of a group municipal group
net metering
group mines
so this language fixes that problem so
that londonderry's fire
fire station could now become part of a
municipal group net metering group
and
the way the language is worded those are
the only persons or the only entities
that
that could do so
so that is the
explanation for the amendment
representative mcgee i don't have the
full
version of 262 here there's a page
missing so i can't refer to the other
sections i'm sorry
so the other sections of the bill that
were removed
were a variety of sections that expanded
net
mirroring uh changed limits for net
metering etc and those uh sections have
all been deleted
by this amendment
um is there any uh go ahead
representative i was just gonna say um
representative cali pitts just secured
me a copy from donna gamache so
um
the pieces that are preserved are the
the group host requirements which was
what you just mentioned plus the um
[Music]
distributed energy resources
um
findings section which was number seven
and then under eight
it's uh
the hosting capacity maps that will be
required by the utilities online
um and then the interconnection so those
are the sections that the the bill will
will contain yeah thank you
okay is there any further discussion on
the amendment
to senate bill 262
see mr chairman excuse me representative
harrington thank you uh
representative what was you were you
referring to some i i've got a one page
one section
is there something i'm missing is this
is the
replaces the entire bill with this
correct
well it amends the bill by deleting
sections one through five and
renumbering the original section six
through ten to read as one through five
so
that is how
resource said it was the easiest way to
do it so that's why i was explaining to
you which sections in the original bill
were going to be maintained i also
wanted him to put all the language in so
we could see it all in front of us but
this is the way they do it so
it's just to follow so if i'm correct
then
six
uh
six through
where are we going here six through ten
stay as written except for the changes
in bold on the one correct okay now i
okay is that clear to everybody
okay see no further discussion i'll ask
the clerk to call the role
on the question of the adoption of
amendment
h mr clerk okay representative thomas
yes representative harrington yes
representative yes representative mirner
yes representative plett votes yes
representative berezni yes represent
bernardi yes representative campbell's
they're not here representative pleasure
yes represent white
yes
represents yes represent kelly pitts yes
representative mann
representative oxenam
not here
uh representative lewicki yes
representative kelly yes representative
mcgee yes representative mick williams
yes representative creation yes
representative partial yes and the chair
yes
that's 20 to zero to two
to two absent okay with a by a vote of
20 to to zero
amendment 1631 h is adopted the chair
now recognizes representative mcgee for
a motion
yes i'd like to make a motion ought to
pass on
representative callie pitts seconds the
emotion the motion of ought to pass as
amended on senate bill 262. do we need
any further discussion on this bill
representative callie pitts please turn
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the role on the question about to pass
as amended on senate bill 262. it does
take me a second to get set up to do
that
uh calling the role for uh octopass's
amendment for 262 rep bill 262
representative thomas yes representative
harrington yes representing otter yes
represent murder yes representatives yes
representative berezini yes
representative bernardi yes
representative campbell's
not here
representative please yes representative
white yes representative samsic yes
representative kelly pitts represent men
not here
yes you are sorry
the wrong one marked off absent
represent oxygen is not here
um uh represent yes
confirmed representative man your vote
was yes
okay the representative wiki voted yes
representative
kelly yes representative mcgee yes
represent mc williams yes rebel
accretion
yes
representative partial yes and the chair
yes that's a vote of twenty zero two
okay
twenty yes zero no and two absent
okay by a vote of 20 to nothing
senate bill 2 6 2 is judged ought to
pass as amended
without objection it'll go on the
consent calendar
and representative mcgee i'll need a
committee report
all right so with that we'll close the
executive session on
senabel 262
and
we will open an exec session on senate
bill 429 fn
this is relative to
the site evaluation committee
and 429
i recognize representative berezni for a
motion
a motion that we judge octopass on sb
thank you
thank you representative nader is
recognized i second the motion it's been
moved and seconded that we judge senate
bill 429
to be
worthy of the motion of ought to fast
is there any discussion
i will point out to everyone
just to jog your memory
that this bill came directly from the
recommendations that were made by the
site evaluation committee study
committee
which met last fall to determine if
there were any improvements that could
be made
to the site evaluation committee short
term
while another
study committee was formed
to pass judgment on the long-term future
of the site evaluation committee
the bill is fairly
long and complicated makes quite a few
changes to the existing site evaluation
committee
but all of these changes have been
received positively
by
the existing members of the site
evaluation committee by members of the
department of environmental services by
the department of energy
and
to date there's been a little opposition
to the changes suggested
by this bill
representative harrington who has served
on the site evaluation committee and was
part of the study committee last fall
that came up with these short-term
recommendations
would like to comment on a few of them
thank you mr chairman um
first of all it gives the commission
committee more flexibility i mean it
sounds a little silly but we literally
would spend sometimes hours trying to
schedule the next site evaluation
committee hearing because you had four
or five commissioners and a couple of
directors in a room
all trying to work their schedules out
and it was really really difficult to do
so this means this allows for designees
it lowers the amount of the quorum from
seven to five which just makes
scheduling a lot easier it's it was
really difficult to explain to people
why the next hearing would be two and a
half months away when they wanted to be
in two and a half weeks so this will
give a lot more flexibility it provides
for a training for the site evaluation
committee which was never in place
before and be quite honest some of the
people on that committee had no idea
what the subject was as far as citing
regulations because it wasn't part of
their regular job
it also allows for
a certificate monitoring compliance
which was never had no funding in the
past so after a project was completed
uh if there was a concern over whether
the certificate was being properly
implemented uh there was really no
mechanism for follow-up on that there
was no funding for anyone to go out and
this would allow for funding so the
department of energy or department
environmental services but that was
appropriate could send somebody out and
say we've got a complaint that you're
not complying with a certificate and
make some evaluation as to whether that
was or wasn't done and it also increases
the fees uh basically basically with
inflation the last fees i think were
eight to ten years ago before they were
increased and it just brings them a
little bit more in line with that so
again as the chairman said this is a uh
a short-term fix looking with the the
idea of the department of energy whether
we need to revise this uh completely
which would be the second step for this
it also it does impose fines for a
violation uh which again was an
oversight in the past and was very
frustrating especially to the general
public involved when they see something
that they know wasn't in compliance with
a certificate and there was almost no
mechanism for them to uh to see that be
stopped and be addressed so those are
the changes i think they're improvements
again it's uh
not the end of the world on these we'll
be looking at it uh with the bill we've
already passed with the idea of how does
the department of energy fit into this
and we need to come look at this
completely differently but in the short
term we need these fixes
discussion on the motion to
judge this bill ought to pass
representative sausage
yes thank you mr chairman
uh mr chairman i agree with representing
harrington's description of what we're
trying to do here and why we're doing it
i think the only
issue of contention that came up in our
caucus
was about the fees structure
which struck us as being a little
strange
this is on page 2
lines 25 through 30.
and
the first line is asking for a 1200
dollar per megawatt fee for the first 40
megawatts of
um this was wind wind energy and uh
number five was twelve hundred dollars
per megawatt for renewable energy
generation facilities
all the other
categories were
in the range of a hundred to uh two
hundred dollars and these were twelve
hundred dollars ten times as much as the
other fees and i believe that uh
representative oxenham was going to
submit an amendment change
for to this bill which would change the
category number five i believe it's to
250 dollars which seems more in line
with what's what was listed here so
i i know since she is not here i was
going to inquire whether there is an
amendment or not
that that she has submitted to the
committee are you aware of that mr
chairman i have seen no amendment no
and it was explained to us by the
department of energy that these numbers
were arrived at
based on the size of the projects
and
all the amended
all the amendment did was just to adjust
those numbers based on the same
adjustments that were made to the other
numbers in the fees
yeah mr chairman i don't believe that we
were that that was explained to us how
that formula should happen
for example that a nuclear generation
facility should only be charged 250
dollars
certainly that's a much more complicated
facility is it's by square foot is it by
what is it by i mean that was not
explained to us we know that there is a
formula being used but nobody explained
the formula here and it still doesn't
make sense to me that something
10 times as much for wind energy and and
other renewable energy generations in
general should be 10 times as much
almost as as the other side doesn't make
any sense it's actually makes very good
sense because it's by meg it's per
megawatt yeah but it's per megawatt for
every facility including the nuclear
right and nuclear facilities are
orders of magnitude
greater in size of course than uh
renewable generation so the total
application fee for a nuclear facility
although very high come before the site
evaluation committee but but that was
not the formula the total size would be
that the fee would be much much greater
yes for a large plant than for a small
solar or wind uh facility
representative harrington you know maybe
one thing that would just help here if
we uh just remember that especially when
you talk about the renewable energy
facilities the overwhelming majority of
those facilities are not juris the site
evaluation committee does not have
jurisdiction over because they're in the
two four five ten megawatt range and
there's no need to file an application
with the site evaluation committee for
under 30 megawatts unless the town
municipality petitions and requests
their help so a lot of those smaller
projects that we typically associate
with the renewable don't even require
the site evaluation committee so there
wouldn't be any fee at all
hopefully that helps a little
okay any further discussion
representative callie pitts i'd just
like a clarification one of the things
we heard was that
the site evaluation committee had a hard
time getting a quorum
and that members often were
unavailable
uh even to to staff it is this site
evaluation committee is just for
clarification are they going to be
permanent members of the site evaluation
committee
that will be sitting
regularly not once you said once a year
maybe once every three years doesn't or
you could have 10 petitions in one year
just a clarification this legislation
does not change the current
structure of the site evaluation
committee it just modifies
some of the legislative components
that
govern
the committee's
operation
now there is another bill that we passed
that would create a study committee to
look at the long-term future of the site
evaluation committee but that bill is a
different effort from this bill which is
to fix some problems that are known to
exist today to see if we can get the
committee to work better well if i may
follow up this bill requires training
provides training and reduces a quorum
so i'm wondering
we're going to invest in training
which to me would seem complicated
and
we're going to reduce the quorum are
these members
as stated in you say there's no change
but there is a change
are they going to be
the current members let's put it this
way the members who are sitting on the
committee
now
yes they're the same members
this bill only requires fewer of them
to constitute a quorum for
a meeting
so there's no change there no change no
well we're going to do training so if
they're the same members that are
sitting on the committee they they would
have been trained i guess
so training was part of the site
evaluation committee
statute
2016 or 2017 to add training
from the department of justice to make
sure that new members of the committee
fully understood the statute
their statutory obligations
this amendment adds additional training
by the department of energy
which they have agreed to supply on the
technical aspects of the work of the
site evaluation committee so it's
actually an improvement
in the training
all right any further discussion on this
question
seeing none
i had asked the clerk to call the role
on the motion of ought to pass on senate
bill 429 representative
representative thomas yes roberto
harrington yes representative nader yes
representative mirner yes representative
plett votes yes representative
yes representative bernardi yes
representative campbell's
not here
representative pleasure yes
representative white yes
yes represent cali pitts yes
represent man
representative knox and i'm not present
representative lewicki yes
representative kelly
yes representative mcgee yes
representative mcwilliams yes
representative creation yes
representative partial yes and the chair
yes the vote is 20 to zero to
okay absent
a vote of 20 to nothing
this bill is judged to be bought to pass
and without objection will be placed on
it will go on to the consent calendar
so with that i'll close the public
hearing on senate bill 429
and
now i will
call us out of recess for senate bill
and
i will recognize representative lewicki
for a motion
to adopt the new amendment just prepared
for us amendment 1639 h representative
thank you mr chairman i move that we uh
adopt amendment
2022-1639h
representative merner is recognized i'll
second that motion moved and seconded
that we adopt amendment
h
so if you look on page two
down at line
the word shall has been changed to
may
that is the only change in this
amendment
is there any further discussion of this
issue
seeing none i would ask the clerk to
call the role on the question of the
adoption of the amendment 1639 h
and i shall do so in a moment
while the clerk is continuing to get
ready for this i will point out to
everyone that we will take a five minute
bio break after the conclusion of this
this public hear this executive session
all right this is adoption of
2022-1639h for house bill
representative thomas
yes representative harrington yes
representative nader yes representative
mirner yes representative platfords yes
representative berezni yes
representative bernardi yes
representative campbell's
they're not here right uh representative
pleasure yes representative white yes
representative samsesh yes
representative calally pitts yes
representative man
reppin oxford not here representative
lewicki yes representative kelly yes
representative mcgee yes representative
mcwilliams
yes representative cuichin yes
representative
yes
representative partial yes and the chair
yes the vote is twenty to zero to two
twenty to zero no two absent okay by a
vote of twenty to nothing
the amendment to
senate bill 395 is adopted i recognize
representative loicke for a motion thank
you mr chairman i move ought to pass as
amended on
senate bill 395
representative burner is recognized i'll
second that motion it's been moved and
seconded that we
judge
senate bill 395 to be
ought to pass as amended
by amendment number
h
and i will
recognize the clerk to call the roll
as soon as he is
ready
wow and while he is preparing himself
i will discuss uh what we're going to do
after we come back from our break
we have um
three bills left
to do after we come back from our break
we'll take up senate bill 265 first
then we'll take up senate bill 448
and the last bill will be senate bill
321. i had originally planned to take up
senate bill 321 sooner
but was informed as we were sitting here
this morning
an error on page 14 of page two
of the amendment
that
had been prepared
i sent this amendment to everyone on the
committee a couple of days ago
turns out that on page 14 or on line 14
on page two the word commission should
be department
so we're waiting on a new amendment
that fixes that one word and when we get
that we will be able to move on to
okay
i've run out of sheets
kristen
is kristin here kristen can you help us
with uh football right here oh you do
okay
a bit of shuffling here sorry about that
all right while he continues to his
preparations here i'm going to recognize
representative thomas who has a question
for members of the committee about
next tuesday april 26th
uh thank you mr chair uh we have been
invited by eversource
to tour their control facility in
manchester in the afternoon of tuesday
we
as you've heard we've scheduled we've
resisted the bill for the morning
but
we're pretty sure we'll be done
by noon so i'd like to hear if there's
any appetite for the committee to
leave from here and go take a tour
at the manchester air resource control
facility or i'm not sure if that's the
exact word for it but it's their up to
state this is their up-to-date
control room that
they'll talk about how they control the
area here
representative nader
let's have a show of hands uh how many
people could attend this event next
looks like a a reasonable number uh
i i am told that um what will happen is
that that we'll go in there and we will
okay
yes i did work for eversource public
service in new hampshire for 23 years
but that ended in 1990 that's a hundred
years ago now and the the
facilities that they have now did not
exist
they had a separate uh uh transmission
operating
remo
remote uh for controlling transmission
up on uh
brooks next to brook street i forget the
name now but that that's gone and they
have it now in in their uh eversource
headquarters
but in distribution as well now
represent plant they have improved the
so representative platt did you just
admit that you're over 100 years old yes
just ask my great grandkids
congratulations on your longevity
okay all right are we ready to call the
roll on the question of ought to pass as
amended on senate bill 395
yes we are and it please do so yes uh
this is octopass's amendment
representative uh thomas yes
representative harrington yes
representative nader yes representative
mariner yes representative platfords yes
representative berezni yes represent
permanente yes representative campbell's
is not present uh representative
pleasure yes representative white yes
represent yes represent kelly piss
yes representative man
uh representative lewicki yes
representative vincent
yes
kelly kelly yep kelly forgive me yes
represent mcgee yes represent mick
williams yes representation yes
representative partial yes and the chair
yes that's the vote is 20
to 0 to up to absent
okay by a vote of 20 to 0
senate bill 395 is ought to pass as
amended without objection we'll put it
seeing no objections it will go on the
consent calendar and i thank you all
that's three bills this morning that we
have
sent to the consent calendar the uh
the speaker of the house and the house
clerk will be very happy and be very
pleased with us
okay so we'll close the exact session on
395 and we will take a five minute bio
break please return to your seats at 10
30 so that we can finish up the three
bills we still have to
just i'm not taking the job next year oh
you
okay let's get back in our seats
everyone so we can uh restart our
okay so
welcome back everybody
i'd like to point out that in the
discussion of senate bill 262 that we
had a few minutes ago
i talked about a uh
a londonderry fire station that had
solar panels on it that was hypothetical
that wasn't uh
about something that actually exists
today although it could
exist in the future so i just wanted to
make sure everybody was clear on that
so that
they understood what we were doing
all right so now let's move on oh and by
the way
we have a new amendment for senate bill
it's amendment 1641h
it's being
sent around the table
and we will work on that uh shortly
but before we do that let's do
senate bill 265 so i'll open an exec
session on senate bill 2 6 five
which is a bill relative to the
aggregation of electric con con electric
customers by county
and i'll representative uh recognize
representative cam brills for a motion
thank you mr chair uh i would like to
make a motion to otp
senator representative cambrils moves
the adoption of
otp for senate bill 265 representative
pleasure is recognized
thank you mr chair i'll second
the otp of senate bill 265.
it's been moved and seconded then that
we judge senate bill 265 to be ought to
pass
do we have any discussion of this bill
essentially this bill adds counties to
the list of
entities that can form
community aggregations it's a relatively
straightforward and simple bill
seeing none it looks like maybe we could
ask the clerk to call the role on the
motion of ought to pass on senate bill
as soon as i put the substitutes in so i
can screw it up
on 265 ought to pass uh representative
thomas
yes representative harrington yes
representative notter yes representative
murder yes represent platforms yes
representative berezni yes
representative bernardi yes
representative campbells yes
representative pleasure yes
representative white yes representative
i'll come back kelly represent cali
pitts
represent oxygen
not here uh representative lewicki yes
representative kelly
yes representative mcgee
yes representative mcwilliams
yes representative creation yes
representative leflam yes
representative partial yes and i'm
calling the role on 265 ought to pass
which is
uh
you can't call on those two they were
not in the room the question was called
uh rep chairman votes
yes
okay
19 yes zero opposed
and three absent
okay by about of 19 to nothing senate
bill 265 is judged to be ought to pass
all right have that discussion later
so
without objection we'll put this one on
seeing no objection
so ordered so we now have four bills
on the consent calendar
the clerk is going to love us that's
that's a different story
i closed the exact session on
senator bill 265
and now i will resume the exec session
on senate bill
and i'll represent it recognize
one six 2022164 one h
i recognize uh representative thomas
second so it's been moved and seconded
that we adopt
amendment 2022 1641 h which just came to
us from
there are copies floating around the
room
i think it should probably
there must be extra copies uh floating
kristen i know i'm sure you obtained
adequate copies
30 copies so there must be copies
all right so this amendment makes one
change on page 2 line 14
it changed what was the word commission
to the word department to make sure
that
it's clear
so is there any further discussion of
the amendment i'll remind members that
the
the meat of the amendment is actually
5 of the
on page 1.
those that's the meat of the amendment
it adds two new sections to the
legislation
that sets up
a condition of approval
and
the limits
to
the size and scope of projects so those
are the two
changes that the amendment makes to the
bill
and
i'd like to know if there's any further
well seeing none
then i will call the question and i
asked the clerk to call the roll
representative thomas
yes representative harrington
yes representative yes roberto murder
yes representative platfords yes
represent berezni yes represent bernardi
yes represent cambrils yes
representative pleasure yes
representative white yes representation
yes represent kelly pitts yes represent
man
oxford represents an absence
representative lewicki
yes
representative kelly yes representative
mcgee yes representative mcwilliams yes
representative creation yes
uh representative partial yes and the
chair yes
uh the vote is 22 to zero
all present in the count of four okay by
a vote of 22 to nothing amendment 1641 h
is adopted
and the chair now recognizes
representative harrington for a motion
i move that uh sb 321 as amended be
ought to pass
second
that's what he said
so it's been moved and seconded that
sb
321 be judged ought to pass as amended
by amendment
1641 h do we need any further discussion
on this bill and that was seconded by
representative
thomas
i asked the clerk to call the role
on the question of ought to pass as
amended for senate bill three
two
one
representative
thomas yes representative harrington yes
representative knighter yes
representative mirner yes representative
platfors representative bereshni yes
representative bernardi yes
representative campbell's yes
representative pleasure yes
representative white yes representative
samsich yes represent kelly pitts
yes represent man
representative oxendine yes
representative wiki
yes representative kelly yes represent
mcgee yes representative mcwilliams yes
representative creation yes represent
yes
representative partial yes
okay by a vote of 22-0 senate bill 321
is
the motion is adopted about to pass as
amended
and without objection we will put this
one on the consent calendar as well
seeing no objections
i think we have set
a new
sdna record at least for this uh session
year for a number of bills on the
consent calendar five out of um
what was the number we had here today
one two three
six seven eight five out of eight wow
that's that's amazing
okay thank you for that
so we'll close the exact session on
senate bill 321
and that brings us to our final exec
session senate bill
448 and the chair recognizes
representative bernardi for a motion
thank you mr chair i move itl
representative white a second it's been
moved and seconded by representatives
bernardi and white
that senate bill
448 be judged to be
itl
is there a discussion representative
bernardi
yes thank you mr chair
this bill is premature it has some
writing difficulties in
in multiple
uh
places it does not use the standard
terminology that is used in the very
first time
uh explaining what the
rationale uh should be or the
characteristics should be for for making
decisions
initially it says they must be
feasible practical and cost effective in
all the other
places in the bill it either leaves out
makes some other
commentary so there's not a consistent
methodology for making decisions and
managing decisions so
it's
the concept here is just premature
representative partial
i do believe that uh when we uh the bill
was presented by senator waters he
addressed that concern
and he thought that the language was on
would be unnecessarily redundant should
all those things appear every time
the fact that it appears once in the
bills establishes the standard
and uh my concern with not passing this
bill at this time is that
we're charged with saving the citizens
of new hampshire uh money where we can
this is a very cost effective program to
[Music]
subs uh to save the citizens a
substantial amount of money and i would
further comment on this legislation
representative loicke
thank you mr chairman i wonder
one thing that doesn't seem to be
addressed is the resale value of the
vehicles or other uh assets and it may
be that we'll save money
on operation and then lose it when we
try to get rid of them at the end
thank you mr chair uh
it's my understanding that
excuse me
when i've taken bills to ols in the past
and there's been repetitive language
they have directed it to be removed and
only the first word to be included i
believe that standard regulatory law
practice we we happen to have a lawyer
in the room we could ask mr crease i
believe whether in fact uh it is
understood that cost-effective um and
the other word are also included by by
reference
okay thank you uh further comments
representative samsich
thank you mr chairman
um just to to follow up on uh
representative luiki's comment
if you look at vehicles that are now on
the market that are
hybrid vehicles or even ev vehicles the
resale value is is higher than a regular
vehicle would be these days and it's not
going to get any lower than that the
other thing is um you know it used to be
when i moved into the state
20 some years ago
or not actually 30 years ago now
we used to be a frugal yankee
state
we would want to be really cheap with
everything we want to save as much money
and energy as we can and this bill is
kind of directing the state agencies to
do the same i don't know why we
shouldn't support that and find a way to
say yes to it
thank you
further comment representative callie
pitts
not going for a pulitzer prize on this
one i do believe that
what we are asking the agencies to do
some of which they have implemented but
i think we need to put it
this puts it on a fast forward basis and
gives us a better handle on what's being
done and how it's being done
i remember the first projects that we
had in here that were changed to change
the lighting
and that saved money
uh and yet when we started it well we
can't do that we can't make people
change the light bulbs yes we can and i
think that there's no problem
with passing a bill like this that is
going to make in the end
the state more efficient and that
doesn't just include these buildings
it includes the buildings we also own in
other areas so i think that's really
important we may see what's going on
here we may see what's happening here
but we may not see what's happening in
other buildings
and i think that this is going to give a
report they have to give a report to
departments to say what's happening in
their other locations
and i think that's
very important especially at this
juncture with energy being
i believe in a crisis mode right now
thank you further discussion
representative bernardi
well second to motion that
is in the crisis mode here we had the uh
the uh the isa folks tell us that we are
at capacity uh on very very
uh cold winter uh days and likely when
we get very hot summer days
and we're adding by this program on an
exponential rate a large number of
electric vehicles
and we're not providing any capacity for
generating the power for that
i think these things need to grow
organically
and i hold to my original comments that
despite the fact that the very first
time feasible practical and cost
effective are mentioned
every section refers to different
functions different agencies doing
doing different things and those words
need to be consistent throughout this
legislation
thank you representative berezni is
recognized thank you chairman uh during
the hearings i heard that um the costs
of electric vehicles in in the
infrastructure is going down
i don't think we need to be early
adopters we can wait a year or two and
and the
additional comments representative mcgee
yes i just wanted to
make a comment on something that
representative bernardi just said about
the capacity on the grid i actually was
speaking with the iso new england this
morning
and on on those very issues
and
we are not at capacity and they are
electrifying um and so
you know if we actually want to go to
the iso or talk with the iso more about
what is real in terms of you know
grid modernization and electrification
and all that what the plans are we
should do that but i didn't want it to
remain in the record that we are at
capacity when there are peaks
we may have to
employ peaking plants for peak demand
but we do have adequacy we do we
definitely have adequate he said in fact
the system is long not short on energy
we have more energy than we need um and
so and there is capacity planning going
on so it we just shouldn't be saying
so was that your regular breakfast uh
conference call with isd car on the way
here actually it was a return from
representative bernardi yeah
thank you mr chairman uh i i don't have
regular breakfast calls with the iso
folks i do
recall
earlier this year going to a session
that they held for all of us where they
gave a report
that we are on the edge of having
blackouts if
we have rolling blackouts if we have any
kind of prolonged cold spell and we just
barely made it through this year so
that's on the record that's published
that's not any telephone call
okay further discussion representative
oxenam
thank you mr chair i understand that
we're going to be coming back um to
consider one of the bills that was on
the agenda for today i i'd like to
suggest that we take this bill and put
it off to that same session so that we
can clear up this minor technicality
about the language and go forward with
this bill
we are we are confronted with a crisis
in the globe and here and we have to do
what we can with what we have this is a
bill that will allow us to do
cost savings and save energy and save
ratepayers money please let us go
forward with it
representative platt i just have to say
i used to have regular breakfast calls
with iso new england but since
representative harrington
yeah fred's back there's no question
about that at least he's not speaking
with a spanish accent after his trip to
mexico
but
uh is to follow up on that discussion i
mean the letter has been out there by
gordon von waldy who's the uh ceo of isl
new england made it very clear we got
close to we were very close to the edge
in fact it was a day in january when i
think we're down to about 300 megawatt
surplus over going to blackout so this
is a real issue that needs to be dealt
with but as far as this bill goes there
is nothing at all you know i hope this
would be without having to have
legislation there's nothing that stops
any department in the state of new
hampshire from going out there and
pursuing an economic way of obtaining
their vehicles and if it's going with
electric and they feel that's the best
way they can do it there's nothing that
stops them from doing that that's uh
they can use their their own judgment on
it so you don't everything does not have
to be emanated by the legislature we
have some pretty smart people that work
for the state and they would figure out
what's the best way to go
further discussion
representative samsic
thank you very much
i just like to say that this bill
actually is helping us if there is any
kind of a
backlog or lack of energy reducing
demand reducing energy use is exactly
what helps us not harms us so i don't
see what connection there is
further discussion
representative occident
thank you very much mr trump i have to
say a lot on this one because i i miss
so much of the morning
on on the ev issue
having a large
stock of ebs acts as a battery it can
actually help us get through peaks this
is a cost-saving measure across the
board and i think we should have the
same 21-0 vote on it that we had on the
i hope that gets you closer to your
okay
representative callie pitts
just
i i just like somebody to refresh my
memory uh from the other party i thought
at one point the governor
had said that this was what was going to
happen that the fleet was going to
become
electrified and that they were going to
be replacing vehicles
you'd have to ask the governor not i
can't speak for the governor you want to
make a call
go ahead i do believe i do believe i
heard that from the governor
okay seeing none i'd like to ask the
clerk to call the role on the question
of itl on senate bill 448 representative
thomas
yes representative harrington yes
representative notter yes representative
mirner yes representative platfords yes
representative berezni yes
representative bernardi yes represent
cambrils yes representative pleasure yes
representative white yes representative
samsesh
no
representative kelly pitts
representative man no representative
oxendium
representative lucky voted yes to
confirm representative kelly no
representative mcgee no
representative mcwilliams
remember the creation no
representable flam
no
representative partial no in the chair
yes
okay by about of 12 to 10 the committee
adopts the resolution of itl on senate
bill 448
and will there be a minority report on
representative creation representative
kreshan will write the minority report
and representative i'll remind you that
it's due by noon tomorrow
okay
so with that we'll close the exact
session on senate bill
and that ladies and gentlemen concludes
our work for the day and i appreciate it
i thank you all very much for your hard
work
we got it done
and we got it done with five bills on
the consent calendar i'm still blown
away by that
so
thanks again everyone we'll see you next
tuesday at 10 o'clock for the resumption
of the public hearing on senate bill 271
thank you and
you